hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by ritual and
we will be looking at professional
ballerina
scout forsythes what i eat in a day on a
rehearsal day
but first let me tell you about my
sponsor ritual so
i've been taking rituals prenatal for
years now because
i really trust their formulations and
their strict testing protocols
i was really excited when i found out
that they were launching a line
of protein powders because as i
discussed in my supplement video right
here
it's not always easy to know which
products that you can trust
so this is a brand new third-party
tested protein powder that
officially launched this month shortly
after i posted my roundup
of some safe third-party tested protein
powders so again it's really important
that we choose a protein powder that is
third-party tested
to ensure that you are getting a
effective product
with traceable ingredients especially
since the supplement world
is otherwise a bit of the wild west but
rituals formulation contains
20 grams of traceable plant-based pea
protein
per serving which helps to support our
muscles
brain bones and satiety and since it can
be hard for some folks to get their
protein in on busy days
it's really a convenient option for on
the go it also has a simple ingredient
list with no artificial flavors colors
or major allergens and it's sweetened
with monk fruit
and fermented sugar cane so it may be a
good
option for those with food sensitivities
so if you want to try out rituals new
protein powder line
you can check out the link in the
description also you can pause the
screen or look at the description to
check out my disclaimer including a
trigger warning to those with current
or previous experiences with disordered
eating as i will be talking about
numbers and portions and of course don't
forget to subscribe to this channel
and ring that little bell so that you
never miss out on a video
all right let's get to the video i'm
typically up around 6 37
i'm i'm an early riser and i really like
it uh
i cannot remember the last time i got to
sleep till seven
and call it early life goals right here
folks i
always try to hit at least a liter of
water a day if not that i
try to go for three anywhere between
that i know i'm feeling good but
anything
less than that is when i'm like i need
water so that sounds like a good
amount of water no water for me not all
rabies causes fear of water
solidarity michael that's irrational the
reality is that
even though public health campaigns have
drilled it into our brain that we need
eight eight ounce glasses of water every
single day
this is just a very very crude
estimation and
average more specifically the institute
of medicine recommends that
most men need around 13 cups and women
around
9 cups but this number changes
significantly
even more so with exercise heat altitude
etc
so my guess is that scout's needs on
training days
may actually be pretty high but rather
than trying to count out or calculate
how many cups of water you're drinking
i say pay close attention to your body
and keep an eye out for some early signs
of dehydration
like thirst fatigue dry lips or
darker yellow pee your pee should be a
pretty
light buttery yellow not clear and also
not dark and cloudy you can shake my
urine check it
check my urine always worth a quick
little peek-a-roo
before you flush scoop it out put it on
top
pepper some nutritionally sometimes and
if i'm feeling a little fancy i'll
toss a little cayenne pepper on there
and a little salt
so once my breakfast is all prepared and
ready to go i bring it over to my
kitchen table
that's when you know it's a good poached
egg we have never seen
a breakfast like this before on youtube
have we
oh but no of course we've got some
avocado toast
she uses either a sourdough or some kind
of
um a sprouted bread she's got one
poached egg
and some nutritional yeast and salt and
pepper on there awesome
i mean i guess this breakfast is popular
for a reason
sprouted bread and sourdough have become
popular lately because they're naturally
easier to digest and also lower in
anti-nutrients and the glycemic index
both options are not gluten free so
obviously would not be appropriate for
somebody with true gluten intolerance
or celiac but they are lower fodmaps so
for folks who are struggling to digest
some bread products
they may be a better tolerated choice as
for the breakfast as a whole
um this looks pretty good to me we've
got fiber and healthy fats in the
avocado
protein and fat in the egg and fiber
rich carbs in the bread
and i love the addition of nutritional
yeast for not only a little flavor
but also for a little extra protein and
vitamin b12
it's not a huge breakfast so i am
interested to see
how far this takes her especially
considering it sounds like she has
a pretty heavy training day ahead right
now i'm trying to limit my coffee intake
and i've
noticed a better effect on my energy
levels throughout the day
and this is me not on coffee so i think
this is a really
good personal observation for scout and
not
a particularly surprising finding to me
so
coffee may be the most widely consumed
stimulant
in the world that works by increasing
brain activity
enhancing focus and delaying fatigue but
generally speaking
we see these effects around an hour
after consumption
and on average they last about five
hours
five hours later for folks who have
created a bit of dependence on caffeine
which
let's be real is a lot of us coming off
of that high
can result in a bit of a crash that
leaves
us feeling maybe even more tired than
where we started
this effect is often exacerbated when
people
substitute energy from food for energy
from caffeine
which is just a big no-no for me
so to avoid the crash we want to make
sure that we are limiting our
consumption to no more than
300 to 400 milligrams of caffeine a day
no
god or about three to four cups of
coffee
earlier on in that day and remember that
the best
quality energy comes from calories not
caffeine
it is important to prioritize eating a
balanced breakfast or meal
to give us the energy that we actually
are craving in scout's case
and this may be true for any performing
artist coffee in large amounts may cause
jitteriness or lack of precision which
i know as a former dancer myself is
really important
but if you need like a little help in
the morning but you want to avoid that
instant energy burst of coffee matcha
also contains caffeine but it also is
paired with a unique amino acid called
l-theanine
that tends to deliver a more prolonged
balanced
hum of energy rather than a huge spike
i always have my journal with me in the
morning and i just love writing in my
journal kind of setting my intentions
for the day
releasing whatever negative energy i had
yesterday
i think journaling is a really amazing
way
to start your day especially for those
of professions where
you know they really need to be on and
focus
at the task ahead research suggests that
journaling can help
to increase cognitive functioning
strengthen the immune system
reduce stress and stress effects and
decrease
symptoms of asthma arthritis and
other health conditions so yeah i think
that is
really great advice from scout i like to
start my day with sweets when i'm doing
rehearsals because
i get so hyper from sugar so if i have
that morning like when i'm walking to
work where i'm like
up here by the time i'm getting to
ballet class my level
my energy level's already starting to do
that crash
so even though scout's talking is a
little bit mumbled here
she actually just said that she avoids
sweets
on training days because it makes her
super hyper so
i want to comment on this idea of sugar
as a scapegoat
for hyperactivity for so long
parents have been convinced that any
amount of sugar will cause
some kind of chemical imbalance that
will make their kids
kind of start bouncing off of walls but
here's the thing
the evidence does not support this
common theory
yes sugar is a carbohydrate and
carbohydrates give you
energy it's also a simple carbohydrate
which
means that it provides energy to the
cells faster than something with let's
say
fiber or protein bound up in it but
research on sugar in children
doesn't actually suggest that it makes
them super hyper
if sugar does have some kind of
measurable effect on children's behavior
it's likely more due to the experience
that having sugar is bound
up in so a birthday party a holiday
a treat this is why as i've discussed in
great detail
in my halloween candy video right here i
strongly advise against
heavy restriction of sugar and sweet
foods with kids
and the same thing goes for us adults
research on
sugar addiction suggests that any novel
experience
is likely to be arousing and stimulating
so
it's very possible that the mere
experience
of allowing yourself something novel
like a donut before 10 a.m
could cause a little extra excitement
but back to what scout was specifically
saying
if i'm not fully in my body focused on
what i'm doing
it can be a risk or a foreshadow for
maybe stepping on my point shoe wrong
not thinking of something
twisting an ankle okay so this makes
sense and i definitely agree i do think
scout's thinking
as an athlete makes sense in the context
of her energy needs for a very busy
rehearsal days
straight up carbs are not going to give
her that even keel to slow
release energy all morning long if she
has a long rehearsal to get through
she has clearly collected data on her
energy needs on rehearsal days
and has found that having a balanced
savory breakfast
with protein fat and fiber-rich carbs is
more sustaining than let's say grabbing
a danish or having a bowl of sugary
cereal
this makes sense this really comes down
to talking about that hunger crushing
combo
of fiber protein and healthy fat but you
also
don't need to avoid sugar or carbs at
breakfast
you just want to aim to make sure that
they're not naked
at the party for promoting a longer
lasting
energy supply so again pair those carbs
with some fiber protein fat and you know
you're gonna be in good shape
after class we have about a 20-minute
break and that's uh
rehydration and usually snacking on
whatever fruit i brought that day
honey crisps are the best apples i
try to go with a whole fruit or a whole
food before grabbing a processed thing
but you know what
sometimes i don't have a banana and a
granola bar's right there
so um i tried to avoid it but if it's
there and i need it
i'm gonna eat it okay so scout has just
completed an
hour and a half rehearsal before snack
and based on my calculations
it's been four hours since she had
anything to eat
i don't know about you but i would be
ravenous
at this point and an apple or like a
granola bar
just wouldn't suffice especially knowing
that i had to get through another
leg of rehearsals before i actually get
to lunch knowing that she
only had one egg worth of protein at
breakfast and just completed
what most adults would see as a pretty
serious workout i would definitely
want to see her get in some more protein
with her carbs so maybe pairing that
apple with some greek yogurt or cottage
cheese
or having it with a protein shake or bar
would be a really good way to fuel up
between those classes
i also brought a little tupperware of
celtic sea salt that i bring to the
studios
i learned not too long ago that putting
a little bit of
uh that in your water is helps with the
minerals that we need
to kind of help digest and hydrate and
it's full of electrolytes
it's a really healthy alternative from a
gatorade or
any kind of sugary energy drink most of
us who are just doing like
a recreational workout here or there
likely
don't need to refuel after our little
gym sesh
with electrolyte replacements or
gatorade like drinks
but if you're doing prolonged continuous
exercise
lasting one to four hours or longer like
scout
a sports drink with sodium and potassium
may be beneficial
it's worth noting however that the
evidence to support
sports drinks that we have has been done
on carbohydrate-based
drinks since there is a benefit in
replenishing
lost glycogen stores in these sports
specific scenarios as well
so like gatorade for example yes it has
electrolytes
but it also has those carbs in the form
of sugar
it does sound like however scout's main
rationale
for using this sea salt is reducing
muscle cramps and
this in theory makes sense however
research actually suggests that
electrolyte and hydration levels are not
the sole causes of exercise induced
muscle cramps supplementing might help
delay them
but the cramping often occurs regardless
and researchers aren't entirely sure why
that is
or what to do about it having said that
if
little salt water helps scout with her
cramps then amazing
like no harm no foul but even if it does
she probably could get away without
having to buy the really fancy
celtic sea salt for her water while
celtic sea salt is
lower in sodium chloride and higher in
potassium than like regular table salt
it is one of the most expensive salt
options
and you'd probably get better bang for
your buck by just putting
a little bit of cheap kosher salt into
your water and then pairing it with a
food source of potassium like an orange
or banana
let's see what's next three o'clock
rolls around and
now we're back on break from three to
four is our lunch break
if i have time on monday i try to meal
prep
right now it's been a veggie soup
because it's cold outside i stole the
recipe from my mom
super nutritious and delicious sometimes
i'll put a grain in there at the bottom
i love farro down at the bottom but
sometimes it's a little too much like
wheat throughout the day for me
wow okay i just need to do a little time
check here
so she had one slice of avocado toast at
7 30 a.m
exercise for an hour and a half then an
apple at 11 45
then another three hours of rehearsals
and now we're having
a bowl of vegetable soup at 3 p.m for
lunch
i get that we all have unique hunger
cues and caloric needs but
i feel like fainting just at the thought
of attempting a pirouette on just that
now obviously that looks like a really
delicious
nutritious soup i mean we've got loads
of fiber-rich veggies we've got a little
fat in there from the cooking oil
and she does say that sometimes she adds
a whole grain like farro in there
but other times she feels like it's too
much wheat
in the day for her i have a lot of
thoughts
first of all i don't think i would ever
characterize
one small piece of bread plus a little
farro
and a soup as too much wheat these are
both super healthy
nutrient dense sources of whole grains
and for an athlete who is
exercising for seven and a half hours a
day
those carb needs are pretty high two
this soup has maybe 150 calories a bowl
and i'm being super generous i wouldn't
even call that a solid snack in my books
never mind a meal
for an athlete now i did notice that
there was maybe a little potato in there
but we could definitely add a little
more carb
in the form of some grains or a couple
pieces of bread
we would also want to add a source of
protein so some
beans or chicken or tofu to help
replenish those glycogen stores and
promote
muscle repair after doing four and a
half hours
of strenuous exercise i mean this soup
could make like a nice little side dish
to a more substantial
lunch meme like a big ass sandwich or
like a massive
wrap or a burrito but honestly just not
enough food
i try to heat it up at my house first
because at the studio they only have a
microwave and i'm very anti-microwave
i think there's a lot of myths floating
around out there when it comes to
microwaves
all of which would probably need a whole
video to fully unpack
but i just want to quickly remind you
that nuking your food
is not dangerous to your health
microwaves do not make your food
radioactive because microwaves
themselves are not
radioactive they are electromagnetic and
they work by causing
water molecules and food to like move
super quickly
which warms up the food also it doesn't
zap
nutrients out of your food any more than
any other cooking method
in fact because it cooks food quickly
it's actually one of the best cooking
methods for nutrient preservation
but anyways if you want to cook things
the old-fashioned way
great i don't care works for me but i
just wouldn't feel
guilty about leaning on some of your
quick cooking appliances
to help you get a balanced meal on the
table super fast
i think of food as fuel and
what is going to sustain me for the rest
of my rehearsal period
okay so i appreciate that being an
athlete often means that you need
to think more than your average person
about nutrition in your meals
and how that can directly impact your
body's performance
i'm just going to call this out right
now as just not
being enough food or enough carbs or
enough protein
to serve as adequate fuel to sustain
that level of intense activity let's see
what's next
the reason i love bringing like
something simple like a soup or a salad
it's easier on my stomach if i don't
meal prep and bring like a soup or
something in from home
there's a make your own solid place
right around the corner
is it just me or has easy on digestion
become wellness culture code for lower
calorie in an era where
bloating has become the new fat
let's break this down folks soup may be
easier on the belly than let's say
a salad because cooked vegetables are
typically easier on digestion so that's
great
but that means that salad is probably
the worst choice for a post or
pre-workout meal
in between these strenuous training
sessions because all those raw
vegetables
are slower to digest and they can cause
a little bit more bloating
and we actually want faster fuel to get
that energy that we need
honestly for sports nutrition her
vegetable soup isn't
even the best option either what ideally
she would want
is a source of lean protein like chicken
or tofu
probably not beans if she wanted to
avoid any digestive discomfort and gas
and some satiating carbs like sweet
potato quinoa
rice or bread a little fat would help
make the meal more satiating since
she does have a little ways to go to get
to dinner but you really wouldn't want a
super greasy heavy meal like something
deep fried
and you would definitely want to keep
those vegetables cooked and almost more
like a garnish
not the entire crux of the meal ugh
and we still have three hours of
rehearsals to go
i'm tired for her i brought myself a
little snack
it's good to have a little backup snack
the hippies are pretty filling because
they're
you know they're puffy so just a couple
of those i'm like okay i've got some
like good fuel and meal a couple of
those are filling
because they're puffed i love these
puffs especially the vegan white cheddar
ones and
they do have a little more protein and
fiber per ounce than let's say
some other kind like cheesy but i
wouldn't characterize a few of these
as filling just because they're puff
they're puffy because they're mainly
air and that air literally dissolves
into mush
when it hits your tongue trigger warning
i am about to casually mention something
pretty problematic so please skip ahead
if you have a history of disordered
eating
but i used to be a dancer myself and for
some reason this statement
just reminded me of the young dancers
that i used to know who would
like fill their stomachs with cotton
balls and tissue paper
to make them feel full without
actual food um
yeah it was bad now i do not
think that this is what scout is
suggesting at all
and i'm also not suggesting that scout
has an eating disorder at
all i'm not her dietitian i don't know
her i'm not here to diagnose
anyone but i do want to flag that if she
were my client and she needed a filling
snack in the middle of her three hour
rehearsal
i wouldn't choose chickpea snack puffs
especially since she talks about how she
chooses food mainly as
fuel this is fun food yes but it's not
great fuel for this level of activity
so if she was loving chickpeas and they
didn't cause her some kind of digestive
distress
a more sustaining option might be
roasted whole chickpeas and like a piece
of fruit
or maybe some hummus with pita bread so
bottom line
puffs are delicious puffs are great and
maybe more satiating than like regular
cheesies but not a super filling option
just because they're voluminous from air
seven o'clock rolls around
when i get home i'm hungry and i just
want something quick and easy so i'll
grab
leftovers or order something at night
for something that's a little bit more
protein heavy i want to like
refuel my body for tomorrow i get this
guy all plated
and this is when i take my lovely little
plate of food over to the table
and i scarf it down and then this is
when i add my sauces
i am so happy new york started carrying
[ __ ] and sauce it is
delicious it's made from almonds i
almost forgot it's not a proper meal
unless you have an avocado in there so
grab whatever you have left over and
scoop it on those veggies awesome so
we've got some
salmon and roasted veggies with salmon's
done with a little teriyaki glaze
tons of different colorful vegetables
we've got a kale salad
top of some [ __ ] and sauce and half an
avocado looks like a beautiful meal
and i love the color that we have going
on
we've got healthy fats from the salmon
avocado and the
cooking oil protein in the salmon and of
course
loads of fiber rich veg there's also a
little carb
as i saw a tiny bit of potatoes in there
but considering the marathon rehearsal
that scout has just completed
on very little fuel this is just not
enough carb to replenish those glycogen
stores
to help her do this again tomorrow this
is just
sports nutrition 101 i mean no amount of
foam rolling
is going to save her body pain from a
low carb low calorie diet like this
and get a little like a kombucha drink
or something i'm not a big drinker
especially during the weeks uh when i'm
dancing
so kombucha is like my little go-to
little after
dancing treat it's bubbly it just tastes
good
i too love a good kombucha as i see it
as just like a flavorful alternative to
plain sparkling water
that is much lower in sugar than soda
pop or
sparkling juice i'm not a big dessert
person if i am gonna have a dessert i'd
rather it be like a fruit
based dessert where it's like a
chocolate covered strawberry or apples
and caramel
but you know occasionally i want a donut
that sounds delicious
and i am glad to see some carbs coming
in here
um i also love the idea of making just
like a humble piece of fruit
like an apple or strawberries a little
more crave worthy
so a little caramel dip or chocolate is
a great way to make
a weekend-worthy dessert on a weekday
on the fly i can consume what i want i
know what
fuels me gives me energy sustains me
throughout the day and i always try to
choose that
but sometimes it's like i just want that
burrito and they're like i want that
donut and that's
okay like i think that's my biggest
thing is giving up the fight
it's it shouldn't be a struggle food
should be yummy and
get make you smile feel you up make you
feel good
my advice though is always consult with
your health practitioner or team
um to help you and choose what works for
you
so i agree with this sentiment even if
it is a little confusing seeing as scout
mentioned earlier that she sees
food as fuel but i agree that food
should make you feel good both
physically and
emotionally i also appreciate that what
we're seeing here on a rehearsal day
may be very different than how scout may
eat
when she's hanging out with her friends
or off season
when maybe there is a little more room
for those donuts or burritos that she
mentioned
but if the goal of this video is to
showcase how to fuel up for
seven and a half hours of intense
physical activity
i just think we really missed the mark
so let's look at the stats
again trigger warning i'm talking
calories here so you can skip ahead
but on this day of eating scout is
getting just over 1600 calories
with 22 coming from protein 53
from carbs and 26 from fat
she's a little low on calcium iron and
zinc but
otherwise is meeting her micronutrient
needs thanks to all of those veggies
and fruit i'm going to comment on the
caloric adequacy
in just a minute what i like here is
that
scout doesn't seem to limit added fat i
don't see
a lot of obsessive behaviors around food
like careful calorie counting or
or weighing foods out which i know a lot
of us saw
in a different what a ballerina eats in
the day
by munchies scout seems to eat a variety
of foods
and her meals seem simple and accessible
there weren't like a bunch of really
strange over-the-top supplements of
specialty ingredients and things like
that really
just mainly a lot of vegetables which of
course may be expensive for a lot of
other people
but thankfully i didn't hear a lot of
demonizing of foods or food groups
and any comments that she did make about
what she eats
or avoids was largely rooted in her own
data
of what she feels works to fuel her body
for work best
now let's talk about what i would
probably suggest if scout was
my client and as a reminder i am not a
sports dietitian
so i did consult a few of my colleagues
with this
whom i will leave links to below but in
short
this just does not look like nearly
enough food
well everyone is unique so i can't say
for sure what scout's unique needs are
our best calculations would put a young
woman
of her size exercising at that elite
level
well above 3000 calories per day that's
more than twice
what she's currently consuming now i
appreciate that scout knows her
body best and this may genuinely feel
good to her
at this moment it also would be unsafe
to ever suggest that somebody
immediately
doubled their caloric intake overnight
so if i was counseling scout
i would be making small changes over
time
but i just mentioned this caloric number
to point out that
from a sports nutrition perspective this
is far from
ideal she was going pretty long
stretches on
pretty small meals and when she does get
a chance to refuel
her choices are far too low calorie to
provide
maximal energy for those muscles to
perform and recover
in other words we need more carbs more
protein
and more calories period a lot more
so this could mean turning that soup
into a side dish to complement a
sandwich
with bread and some kind of lean meat or
tofu or protein
and making sure to throw a sweet potato
or rice or pasta into her dinner meal
i would also beef up those snacks to
make sure that they're not just
filling because of their volume but
because of their actual
nutrient value again this may be working
for scout right now
and i fully acknowledge that she knows
her body better than i would but i just
need to address this for
all the recreational dancers or athletes
who are watching
and thinking wow i must be eating way
too much
food dancers need a lot
of food i also have to address the
elephant in the room and that is the
prevalence of disordered eating
in the dance community according to a
large systematic review and
meta-analysis
12 of ballet dancers have some
form of diagnosed eating disorder that's
a really big number
and i would bet that that number is
insanely high if we
also fact in undiagnosed forms of
disordered eating
like orthorexia but when you think about
the culture
it's not really that much of a surprise
so
for one ballet rehearsal takes place in
skin tight leotards surrounded by
mirrors
where every bump and curve can be
analyzed
and scrutinized two the most successful
female ballet dancers
are often described as floating ethereal
light as a feather as they're expected
to leak through the air or
be lifted without any effort or strain
three
young girls start dancing pretty early
when their bodies are
underdeveloped and small and typically
continue throughout puberty
when they just naturally start to grow
so this inevitable and healthy growth
trajectory can often be a catalyst for
trying to manipulate
and prevent those changes and finally we
can't forget about the core
culture of dance where control and
discipline are celebrated
and synonymous with success it's a no
pain
no gain world my mom was actually
professional ballerina
and she used to tell me that her
teachers would throw dishes at her for
not performing to their standards
[Music]
and if your toes weren't bleeding you
weren't doing it right honestly my mom's
feet are
permanently wrecked from the abuse
so clearly it takes a lot of control
and self-discipline to do something
every day
that gives you pain and that same
discipline
is often required to maintain an eating
disorder as well
but here's the thing not only does
undereating result in
sub-optimal performance and training
potential but there's also a
very real risk of long-term health
outcomes like
delayed puberty amenorrhea infertility
osteoporosis and severe injury i want to
make it clear that i am not anti-dance
i danced competitively my entire life
and while i don't have daughters i would
enroll my boys
in dance in a heartbeat if they showed
interest but
the statistics don't lie and the reality
is that
under eating is often baked into the
culture itself
it becomes so second nature that a
mature dancer like scout
probably doesn't even notice that she's
doing it she might even think that she's
sharing a day of eating that
debunks the myth that dancers don't eat
because she feels
she eats so much more than her peers
that is how much worse
i guess it can be that is what living
and breathing in
disordered culture for so long does with
your relationship with food
it turns external messages about food
into
real internal ones to the point that
they feel
like intuition so let's keep the
comments here kind
empathetic and supportive i don't think
scout is trying to share misinformation
about what to eat
she just has been fed so much of it all
of her life herself
and on that note that is all that i have
for you guys today
thank you again to ritual for sponsoring
this video if you liked it
be sure to give it the thumbs up leave
me a comment below with who you'd like
to see me review next
subscribe to the channel and i'll see
you next time on abby's kitchen
bye
you